Good afternoon, everyone. Welcome to this session, Advancing Early Phase
Pediatric Clinical Trials to Turn Promising Agents into Actionable
Evidence. My name is Meredith Irwin, and I'm the chair of the Pediatric
Cancer Working Group of AACR, and it's my extreme privilege
and pleasure to chair this session today.
Oops.
Okay, we'll wait until the slides come up, maybe.
Yeah.
We're very close now.
I have no disclosures. I can say that now. That's pretty straightforward.
Okay. Should I turn it now? We're good? Okay.
All right. So we have three speakers, and I'm going to
introduce all three of them to you right now and then give a very
brief introduction before we get right to it and talk about
these three very important topics today. So first, I have Dr.
Jerry McGean, who is the vice president of the Menin program at Syndax
Pharmaceuticals, followed by Dr.
Nicole Dresner, the Deputy Directory, Division of Oncology II at the
US FDA, and then ending the
session prior to our discussion and our panel is Dr.
Brenda Wigle, who's the Vice President of Clinical Research Administration
and Industry Engagement at St.
Jude. So what I wanted
to outline on the next three slides, just to set the stage for
today's talk, is really the three broad steps en route from a
drug being discovered all the way to the approval process
and hopefully access for our pediatric patients.
So I wanted to do a bit of a status of where, from my perspective
as a clinical trials and translational researcher, we are right
now.
So at this meeting, we've certainly all seen amazing discoveries, and this is just
an example of one of the many incredible reports put out by the
AACR. But where I think we need to get is turning all of these incredible
discoveries to more drugs that we have available for trials and ultimately
treatment of our pediatric patients. And I just pulled some of the data.
There's many articles, as you all know, about the challenges in
this area, but I pulled this data from the WHO
2023 report, where they were able to
look at all of the pediatric oncology drugs that were
registered on phase one and two clinical trials over this 15 year
period. And I think it doesn't take a lot of math to figure out this
number is not adequate, and we need to get farther.
All these discoveries we're seeing today, hopefully when somebody presents a slide
like this in the future, these numbers will be significantly higher.
And this first step, development, we'll hear from Dr.
McGean of some of the successes that they've had with the menin
inhibitors and hopefully can build on some of those as we move forward.
And then in the second talk, we'll really be talking more about pediatric clinical
trials. And once we have a drug, as many of us know,
there's so many barriers to getting the drug for a trial and then opening a
pediatric trial. And this is just one figure from a paper
led by Dr. Steve Dubois from the Dana-Farber, where he looked at the
actual time between the first in human, generally an adult trial,
to the first in pediatrics. And you can see that over this 10 year period,
it was about six and a half years as the median.
And that's just also, in my mind, not okay.
And I think Dr. Dresner and others on the
panel later can hopefully help us think about ways to shorten this period.
And finally, once we actually have that pediatric trial, we finish it, maybe even
publish it, what's the likelihood of that drug actually going all the
way to getting an approval from either the FDA, EMA, or other
regulatory agencies? A study which is in
press from Doctors Sam Martin and Steve Dubois looked
at this end of this period when you had a pediatric
trial and what was the likelihood of a drug making it all the way to approval.
And you can see here, we love our Kaplan-Meier curves in
oncology, that there's about a 50% chance of getting an
approval, an adult indication, after there's been a
pediatric trial. However, if you look on the right now, you can see that
the attrition from a pediatric perspective is so much
less, even when there's been a pediatric trial for a drug.
So I think this really is a call to action for how we can
fix or improve these three parts of this pathway to get
drugs into the clinic.
So I'm going to turn over the stage now to Dr.
McGean to tell us the incredible story of menin inhibitors.
Thank you.
Just advance.
I use just the advance. I would just do that one.
Okay.
All right. All right. Listen, I want to thank the organizers for inviting us here
today to talk about the path to approval for menin and how we were able to
include pediatrics in our final analysis.
And if you don't know, so revumenib is a protein-protein
interaction inhibitor that was approved for the treatment of
relapsed/refractory acute leukemias in adults and
children over one year of age, and it's basically targeting
KMT2A rearranged acute leukemias
and also NPM1 mutant leukemias as well.
We're going to talk a little bit about how we ended up working on this, but
also the timeline to get to approval and some of the things that we did, both
on the regulatory side, the clin pharm side, and also on the
CMC side, that kind of enabled getting pediatrics into the study.
So if you don't know how revumenib works, so essentially,
as I mentioned, it's a protein-protein interaction inhibitor that binds to
meninAs you can see in the cartoon on the left, so menin is a
scaffold protein that's attached to chromatin, and it sits in your transcription
start sites. And in this case, if you're looking, say, at a KMT2A
rearranged leukemia, that KMT2A fusion protein actually binds
with high affinity to menin at transcription start sites, and essentially
pulls together a large active transcription complex that
drives a leukemic transcription program, which is dominated by what's called a
HOX/MEIS signature. So most
leukemias are cells that are sensitive and menin have this HOX/MEIS signature.
And that signature drives a leukemic transcription program that blocks
differentiation, and essentially leads to self-renewal and proliferation and
eventually acute leukemia.
The menin inhibitors work, as shown on the right,
rebumenib in this case, binds to menin with high affinity, blocks its
interaction with the KMT2A fusion protein, and in so doing,
breaks apart that transcription complex and essentially releases menin
from chromatin. And once that transcription complex is gone,
the leukemic transcription program collapses, and then the cells die
from either differentiation or apoptosis.
Now, we've always been interested historically in pediatrics
with this KMT2A leukemias, and that's really
an historical perspective. So these
rearrangements were first actually identified in infant
forms of B-ALL over 30 years ago.
And since then, they've been characterized across a wide spectrum of ages.
Actually, the adult population that has KMT2A rearranged is
actually larger than the pediatric population.
But what sets the pediatric population apart, I think, is the
frequency in some of the subsets in the pediatric patient.
And if you look on the right-hand side, this is looking at ALL and AML.
Three on the left are ALL, and the three on the right are AML by different
ages. And what you can see is that in adult
KMT2A rearranged, whether it's ALL or
AML, you basically are looking at
5% to 10% of the leukemias having this.
What's interesting is if you look in infants, and this is again where it was first
found,
you can see that infant AML has about 40% plus
KMT2A rearranged, but really it's in the infant
ALL that it's particularly notable that
80% or so of the
kids that present with infant ALL are actually
KMT2A rearranged. So we've always had this
in the heart and in our minds to try to find a way to peds.
And I think it's kind of evident when we first talk
about the first kind of clinical advisors program we had before we ever went near
the clinic. But it was organized by Scott Armstrong, who was our
collaborator since 2014 on large aspects of this program.
And Scott pulled together a group in New York City, and he had, you can see here
the top three with the check marks are actually practicing clinical
pediatric hemonc doctors. So Scott was at
MSKCC and then went to head the pediatric oncology at
Dana-Farber. Louis Silverman was at Boston Children's, and
Pat Brown at that point was at John Hopkins.
The other two attendees at that meeting were Eytan Stein, who ended up becoming the
PI for the registrational study, the AUGMENT101
study, for the monotherapy in relapsed refractory leukemia, and Ross Levine,
who's been a collaborator and advisor on all aspects of the preclinical and the
clinical program as well.
So I'm going to walk through the timeline of when we've essentially filed the
IND to how we got to approvals and make a few highlights along the
way. So if we start on the left, we filed our IND, and it was
accepted in mid 2019.
We actually dosed our first adult patient in November of
2019. And fortunately, we did have monotherapy activity,
and we first presented the first in-human results here at
AACR in 2026. It was one of the new drugs on the horizon
saw.
Subsequently, a few months later, the FDA did allow us to open the
enrollment to
children and down to 30 days of age, and we'll talk
about how we got there in a little bit.
And then very quickly, we moved from Phase 1 to Phase 2 and did the registrational
study and essentially filed the NDA, started filing the NDA on
October 23, four years after we had dosed our first patient, and we
filed it under real-time oncology review, RTOR, and we were
approved at the end of 2024 in KMT2A, and then approved for
NPM1 mutant AML in end of '25. Now, a
couple things to note here. This happened very quickly.
So it's four years from the first dosing to basically the
NDA. And
we did this, our regulatory team was extremely
engaged, and along the way, we had great interactions with the FDA.
Our project team and our project manager were phenomenal.
And as you'll see, we had some special needs that they addressed, and they were
incredibly flexible and responsive.
And when we needed things, they were done overnight, over weekends.
They were really, really advocates for us, pushing this into the
pediatric population because they knew there was an unmet need, and
the biology had a high overlap and a biological rationale.
So one other aspect of that, when we filed the
IND, we had a pre-IND meeting, and we actually petitioned
to include children in the initial study.
The FDA pushed back. They said, "No,
we don't know PK safety and a number of other legitimate
parameters about this population, but we'll try to find a path to get there." And
so what ended up happening was a little
twist.So we dosed our first
adult in November of 2019, but the first patient to get
the drug was actually a child. So this happened in
October 2019, and the first patient was a
year-and-a-half-old,
relapsed/refractory KMT2A, being tended to by Dr.
Neil Shukla at Sloan Kettering, who knew what we had,
who knew what we were working on, and basically made the case based on the
high unmet need and the rationale that we should probably test this
in a pediatric population. So what we did was put together
what's called a single patient protocol.
And so what's important here is that single patient protocol allowed us to collect
data and that we basically filed it under our IND, so it
wasn't an investigator going off and doing what they want.
We wanted to make sure we got the data that we needed, and the FDA
was asking for, to
expand the population beyond adults into lower age groups.
And that SPP, once that got out, we actually had a number of
requests for compound. And one of the key things there was we were able
to collect PK and some other safety parameters and even some
efficacy data in these patients as well.
So if we look at this little card, I'll just walk through sort of left to right at
the top. So what we needed was more safety data,
more PK data, more efficacy data. And
if you're going into pediatric population, you have to remember you're basically
dealing with
something that's a person that's five kilograms up to 75 kilograms.
So,
one of the key things we had to do was show that their exposures were similar
across the ages. There could be some developmentally
regulated aspects of uptake or clearance, but we ended
up finding that actually the exposures were pretty proportional between adults and
humans on a dose basis or, say, a mg per kg or
mgs per meter squared basis.
The other piece of that is that
we're trying to get kids onto the drug trial, but the other question is how do you
get the drugs into the kids? It's not trivial.
So we spent a lot of time trying to define appropriate formulations
to get exact doses that we could administer to
basically get a normalized dose for all
age groups and all sizes. We needed to find appropriate
formulation. That was an ongoing task.
And then we needed to do it with guides through interacting with the FDA and then
also doing it obviously in a very compliant fashion.
And so I said that Neil was able to get the
SPP protocol cleared because there was a clear biological
rationale for using menin inhibitors in infants and
children. And
I'm just taking a figure out of a paper that was published with Scott Armstrong
that we were on in 2019, and some of the rationale for going into
pediatric patients is shown here.
This was studies sponsored by the NCI and the
Preclinical Pediatric Testing Consortium, which may have changed its name.
I think it might be called Pivot now.
But this is
a great resource, that's all I can tell you, that the NCI has, that you can
test new agents in rare or unmet needs in
pediatric cancers, and they do a phenomenal job.
And so the picture on the right just shows the results of a study we did
with Dr. Richard Locke at Sydney Children's.
And essentially what we've done here is taken eight pediatric
PDXs. They're all B-ALL PDXs over a range of
translocations. And we've treated these animals for 28
days with rev and then followed them.
So on the chart, you see all the animals that were in the study.
Everybody showed up. And we're looking at any kind of treatment and survival
benefit. And what we noticed right away was that essentially seven out of the
eight PDXs had an obvious and significant survival
benefit, some two to three months, some out to 10 to 12 months, and actually some
of these animals were followed over a year.
And so we obviously had a single agent effect, and so it was compelling rationale
to biologically to go into the younger patients.
And at the bottom is a Philadelphia chromosome positive
leukemia, which shouldn't respond, and it doesn't.
And so I think having this in place was one of the key
drivers for everybody, at least on the scientific rationale side and actually the
preclinical pharmacology side, to take the leap and go ahead
and start honoring some of these SPPs and requests from the
pediatric docs.
So
just overlooking everything that we've done here.
So these single patient protocols became very important.
We quickly established that the exposure across the
different sizes and ages of children was quite
proportional between adults and children.
There was really nothing special about uptake or clearance that changed the PK
of the compound.
It allows to collect a lot of data, and essentially,
once it was consistent, then we were open the enrollment to the patients down to 30
days of age.
These are key things. So, in 2020, as I just said,
we were able to go down to 30 years of age, and then in 2022,
we're actually able to open a study where we're looking at revumenib in
combo with intensive chemotherapy.
Because again,
Richard Locke's lab in Sydney had generated some chemo combo data
with rev and some of these ALLs and also shown, again, really quite
beneficial treatment effects. So at the end of the day, if you look at
when we registered the compound, we had over 130 SPPs
that came with the filing as well. So you can see here 25
infants, 78 children, 29 adolescents.
So it was a pretty heavy lift, I think, on the regulatory side.
They had to do a lot of SPPs, and
so I think they spread the wealth there, and everybody was spending a lot of time
on that, so.So now we've already
got these
patients, or the young patients are already now getting enrolled
in the study. The question is, how do you get drug to them?
Yeah, and what are the kind of hurdles of dealing with a drug
in
a young patient population? I think one of the things you have to realize is that
revumumab is an amine. It's basic. It's a protonated amine.
And I don't know if you
ever dealt with these substances.
Protonated amines tend to be very bitter, and revumumab is no
exception. It does not taste good.
So,
you don't want to taste your drugs usually.
what we needed to do was try to get it into a form that was presentable and that
we could dose accurately into the smaller patients.
And one of the things about being a protonated amine, this actually gave revumumab
some quite good solubility. So, it's soluble at mgs per ml,
many mgs per ml, actually. And so we were able to basically make
accurate concentrations of rev as liquid solutions that really
facilitated the administering, especially into the younger patients that might be,
say, on NG tubes. So we could precisely and accurately deliver
doses to these patients, and be sure that we weren't putting
anybody at risk and that the exposures were really quite proportional to what we
wanted.
We didn't see any difference in the PK in the younger patients.
And then
the last bit of it is actually just a talk about the physicality of the
CMC aspect. So when you think about somebody
says, "I have a crystal and a solid," you think, "Oh, salt. It's really solid.
I can pour it out and it runs well." Well, we had a crystal and solid, but it was
a fluffy, sticky, and not very flowing solid.
So it was not trivial, just mechanically, to deal with it.
So,
I'm going to go through some of the presentations we had clinically, and then just
how they all fit into the overall program.
So we actually started out in capsules.
So basically, there was a revumumab blend in capsules.
And given that it was sticky and fluffy, it actually was staticky and held a static
charge. And so when you were basically doing production, you
basically were building up static charge.
And when they did production, they used to actually walk around with an anti-static
gun to kind of neutralize the charge on the trays.
It's not
funny in some ways, but it is. But anyway.
But the advantage of having these capsules available and knowing about the
solubility of rev is that early on, we used what we
call extemporaneous solutions, essentially.
You know the content in your capsule, so if it's, let's say 115
milligrams, you can put
it in 10 mils, you know it's 11.5 mgs per ml.
So we could
basically use these capsules, discard the shell, and essentially make
up liquid solutions to an accurate concentration.
And in the pharmacy in the hospitals, it was very doable.
And so we also had to do some characterization of those solutions to make sure they
were stable, that the compound didn't oxidize or hydrolyze or anything like that.
So with stability, you go along with that.
So, those are just practical aspects that you need to deal
with when you're putting these things together.
And so at this point now, we are at the point we have a liquid formulation.
A couple of key aspects here, since it does taste bitter.
We spent, actually, it wasn't me, it was actually our CMC group
led by Aaron Marolewsky. They did a really phenomenal job.
To hide the bitter taste, we spent a long time trying to
find a formulation with acceptable excipients which
could hide the taste and be palatable in some way.
And then at the same time, to make a stable or shelf-stable
solution, we had to find a number of preservatives or things that could basically
keep it stable and make sure it didn't oxidize or hydrolyze over time, and it
can have a shelf life that would be easy for, say, 28 days to administer a
drug on one cycle.
And now we've kind of moved ahead with the program.
So we got rid of the capsules during the development.
We replaced them with tablets. Right now, we have two presentations.
We have 110 milligram and 160 milligram tablet.
And realizing that pediatrics, those are still too big.
We actually had a campaign and developed a 25 milligram tablet as well.
So, younger patients who can swallow a tablet can take that, and it also has the
advantage that it can be readily dissolved if needed to
generate a liquid formulation.
So, a few of the lessons that we learned along the way, and I hope maybe they
translate and can help anybody else out there that's in the middle of a development
program or considering a development program in pediatrics.
Engage the regulators early.
Even though we weren't allowed to use children in the original enrollment
criteria, we quickly were able to switch that and open
the trial to younger patients based on data that we were able to generate in
collaboration with the FDA. We basically set all the metrics that they
want. They set the metrics, and we were able to fulfill them, and we basically were
able to change the enrollment at that point.
I think you need to
think creatively.
Not every solution's obvious.
The single-patient protocols ended up being obviously the key for us,
I think, for advancing the program as quickly as we did in the pediatric patients
and collecting those data, not only for safety and PK, but also for
eventual registration. And don't underestimate the
CMC
aspects of this. If you're lucky, like us, your compound is soluble.
You can administer it in an accurate dose that's proportional with the size,
weight of the subjects. But
there may be a little more of a lift if you're doing something
with a solid that's not highly soluble.
So you have to get creative on how to make something that's sort of uniform, and
titratable, and dosable at the same time.
So.And we're going to wrap up
there, and then I'm just basically going to
acknowledge and thank everybody, especially the patients who are enrolled in these
trials, their families, their caregivers.
I'll read this out, actually. Study investigators, study teams, and the clinical
researchers. A phenomenal number of people are involved in this.
And then a number of current and former Syntex employees who helped
get this, not only into the clinic, but to the registration.
And FDA for really highly constructive interactions throughout this entire
process. They were true collaborators all along the way.
And then, all the drug substance and people who make the drug
and helped with dealing with these novel formulations as
well. So, thank you for your time and
that's it.
Questions.
Questions later.
That's
good.
Yeah, I guess.
Hi, good afternoon, and thank you to the AACR Pediatric Cancer Working Group for
having me. So happy to be here. My name is Nicole Dresner.
I'm a pediatric oncologist and the Deputy Director of the Division of
Oncology 2 at the FDA.
I'm going to give a brief overview of the regulatory considerations that we
apply when we are reviewing proposals for early phase and later
phase pediatric cancer trials.
These are my disclosures.
So back in 1995, the American Academy of Pediatrics published
guidelines on the ethical conduct of studies to evaluate drugs in
pediatric populations, noting that there is a moral imperative
to formally study drugs in children so that they can enjoy equal
access to existing as well as new therapeutic agents.
These guidelines were updated in 2010, after the passage of some of the
legislation I'll discuss later in the presentation.
And the authors then reiterated the importance of formal research, stating
that the performance of research studies to evaluate drugs in children is
critical for determining the safety and efficacy of medications in children.
Without this type of research, they went on, medication use in children will be
limited to extrapolation from adult studies or off-label use for
indications that have not been studied in children, thereby putting them at
increased risk of adverse effects.
These notions really underpin the regulatory considerations that we
apply to all phases of drug development for children with cancer to
uphold the rigorous standards of safety and efficacy while accounting
for the flexibility that is often required for rare diseases with a
high unmet medical need.
So who are the FDA staff reviewing pediatric oncology drug
development? The Oncology Center of Excellence, or OCE,
was established in 2017 to facilitate the development and
clinical review of oncology products by uniting scientific
experts across the FDA's product centers to conduct
expedited review of drugs, biologics, and devices.
Pediatric oncologists and other review staff with expertise in
evaluating pediatric oncology therapeutics, including non-clinical
pharmacologists, are incorporated throughout CDER and CBER
divisions, overseeing the full spectrum of pediatric cancer indications, as
shown on the slide.
As I mentioned, my division, Division of Oncology 2, reviews drugs and some
biologics for pediatric solid tumors, neuro-oncology, and rare
tumors.
So during this talk, I'm going to discuss the unique regulatory considerations for
early pediatric oncology drug development.
I will next review considerations for the inclusion of adolescent patients in
adult oncology clinical trials.
I will discuss specific early phase trial design elements that may facilitate
drug development for pediatric patients, and I will discuss some of the
legislation that has affected pediatric oncology drug development
to date.
Inherent to pediatric drug development is the notion that information and data from
properly evaluated medicines should be assessed in a timely manner to ensure
the proper use of medicinal products.
And this includes, as you just heard, the development of pediatric formulations to
ensure access across the entire relevant age spectrum.
While some principles that underlie adult drug development apply to children,
there are unique considerations for the development of
drugs for pediatric populations.
Beginning with non-clinical study, the requirements for data submission
depend on whether the pediatric trial is also a first-in-human trial.
If the pediatric trial is not first in human, additional toxicology
studies prior to initiating a clinical trial are often not
necessary. And juvenile animal toxicology studies are
generally only required if drug development is exclusively in
pediatrics, or if there are potential long-term development
toxicities that are anticipated by the drug's mechanism of action
or earlier studies. Ideally, for a clinical
development program,
for pediatric patients should be adequate to support an evaluation of dosing,
safety, and efficacy and include plans for pediatric formulation
development. For both adult patients and pediatric patients, the
standard for drug approval is the same and requires a demonstration of
substantial evidence of effectiveness through adequate and well-controlled trials.
There are several other regulatory considerations that are unique to early-phase
pediatric oncology drug development.
Although patient populations are small, the pharmacokinetics of a drug should
be evaluated over the entire pediatric age range in which the agent will be
used. Initial pediatric study plans for early pediatric drug
development should address the entire pediatric age range from birth
to less than 17 years of age, though plans may include justification for
waiver of clinical study in a particular age group if studies in that
population would be infeasible. Typical age groupings are listed on
the slideAnd the FDA
generally requests that sponsors propose a reasonable minimum
number of patients to study in clinical trials in each relevant age
group.
For early trials in particular, additional safeguards for children in clinical
investigations are required by law.
In general, pediatric oncology clinical investigations are considered to involve
greater than minimal risk to children, but also present the prospect of
direct benefit to individual subjects.
For these types of investigations, the Code of Federal Regulations
requires that these risks be justified by the anticipated benefit to the
subjects. The relation of the anticipated benefit to the risk is
at least as favorable to the subjects as that presented by available
alternative approaches, and adequate provisions should be made for
soliciting the assent of pediatric patients and the
permission of their parents or guardians.
Finally, given the cost associated with clinical trial conduct, there is usually
insufficient financial incentive for the pharmaceutical industry to support early
phase pediatric oncology development.
I will discuss some legislation that was enacted to at least partially address this
challenge in pediatric oncology later on in my presentation.
Due to these and other considerations, initial trials in pediatric patients
for many drugs are typically conducted years later than adults and
often after the drug is already approved for adults.
But through the dedicated efforts of many collaborators here and across the
government, academia, industry, and patient advocacy, these challenges are
being addressed in many different ways.
I'm now going to talk about adolescent patients in adult oncology trial because
adolescent patients represent a pediatric age group for which additional
considerations for inclusion in early phase trials apply, namely
when adult oncology clinical trials are being conducted in the
adolescent disease of interest.
FDA's guidance for industry on inclusion of adolescent patients in adult
oncology clinical trials states that adolescent patients should be
eligible for enrollment at all stages of drug development when the
histology and biologic behavior of the cancer under investigation
is the same in, or the molecular target of the drug is
relevant to, cancers in both adults and adolescent
patients. The guidance indicates that generally, first in
human or dose escalation trials should include adolescents after some
initial adult pharmacokinetic and toxicity data are obtained
and should be enrolling patients with relapsed or refractory cancers.
However, depending on the rarity of the disease and the unmet medical need,
as well as experience with the drug or drug class, the FDA teams
may exercise flexibility on how much data constitutes some.
For activity estimating or confirmatory trials, adolescents should be enrolled
simultaneously with adults.
These considerations for adolescents in adult oncology trials are supported by the
knowledge that systemic exposure and clearance of drugs is generally similar
between the two groups. Selection of an appropriate dose for adolescent
patients should be based on the pharmacokinetic and pharmacodynamic
characteristics of the investigational drug, with consideration of body size
effect on drug exposure, toxicity, and activity data if
available, the therapeutic index of the drug, and dose and
exposure response relationship in adults.
For drugs with body size adjusted dosing, adolescents should receive the
same body size adjusted dose as adults.
For drugs administered as a fixed dose in adults, a minimum
body weight threshold should be defined, which is generally 40 kilograms.
Adolescents who weigh at least 40 kilograms may receive the same fixed dose as
adults, and those who weigh less than 40 kilograms should revert to body size
adjusted dosing. For adolescents in adult trials, the study
safety monitoring plan should include long-term follow-up of potential
developmental toxicities when applicable.
The same ethical considerations that apply to early phase pediatric clinical
trials also apply to adult clinical trials that enroll adolescent
patients. Institutional review boards must ensure that the provisions
of 21 CFR 50.52, shown here, are
satisfied before approving the studies.
Considerations should include disease and/or molecular target, available
therapeutic options, and dose level for first-in-human trials.
However, enrollment of appropriately selected adolescent
patients in relevant adult oncology clinical trials with appropriate
dose considerations and adequate safety monitoring is justified
given the severe and life-threatening nature of their disease.
Beyond the specific case of adolescents in adult oncology clinical trials, there
are some early phase trial design elements which may facilitate drug
development for the rest of pediatric oncology.
Each of these elements on the slide here could really individually comprise an
entire session,
but I have listed some different considerations for trial designs for early phase
pediatric clinical trials that may facilitate development in these rare patient
populations. Pediatric oncology clinical trials, as
with adult trials, are often thought of as representing distinct
phases of development, each with separate goals and endpoints.
The earliest phase trials are often considered insufficient to support a
regulatory evaluation for safety and effectiveness, as their goal
is to identify toxicities and a safe dose of the investigational drug to move
forward. However, the design and initiation of every new
clinical trial requires time and resources, which may be
mitigated by seamless designs that incorporate adaptive elements
and support clinical and regulatory decision making.
Moving from dose finding to dose expansion with an efficacy endpoint in the
same trial, particularly in diseases where go, no-go thresholds are
agreed upon, could yield a data set that is suitable for regulatory
submission and marketing authorization, even if the trial is considered early
phase.Furthermore, early clinical trials which
include dose escalation may be expedited by rational dose selection
approaches, which may include PK or exposure-guided dose levels
rather than traditionally identified starting doses that risk being
ineffective, model-informed drug development approaches,
interpatient dose escalation, and early introduction of combination
regimens. We understand that adoption of these elements adds
complexity to an already very complicated disease space, and
recommend early engagement with the FDA.
There are a variety of formal meeting mechanisms that can begin at the
pre-clinical stage and provide support and collaboration throughout the entire
development cycle.
One such scenario that benefits from early engagement with the FDA is when an
academic or industry sponsor is planning a first-in-human trial in
pediatric patients with cancer. Although there is no formal FDA
guidance addressing this topic, in general, if an investigational
product that is solely intended for pediatric cancer that does not
also occur in adults, first-in-human studies in children are
justified on a case-to-case basis.
When evaluating each case, we consider the type of cancer and
the intended patient population, the strength of the pre-clinical data,
the nature of the therapy and route of administration, and often recommend
staged enrollment by age when reasonable within pediatric age
groups. It is important to emphasize the impact of strong
pre-clinical data supporting the drug's mechanism of action and pre-clinical
activity in the specific pediatric cancer planned for clinical
investigation to provide a rationale for initiation of a
first-in-human trial. Given that clinical context varies widely
across the spectrum of pediatric cancer types and therapies, these
study plans should be discussed early at the pre-IND stage with the appropriate
FDA review division.
Finally, I will give you a brief overview of the legislation that affects pediatric
oncology drug development, and provide some incentives and requirements
to facilitate both early phase clinical trials and the entire development programs
through marketing authorization.
Congress initially passed the Best Pharmaceuticals for Children Act, or BPCA, in
2002, and the Pediatric Research Equity Act, or
PREA, in 2003, and these were each made permanent in 2012.
Under BPCA, sponsors of certain marketing applications and
supplements can obtain an additional six months of marketing exclusivity if
the sponsor voluntarily submits information responding to a written
request issued by the FDA relating to the use of a drug in a pediatric
population. Under PREA, sponsors of certain marketing
applications and supplements are required to submit pediatric assessments unless
they receive an applicable waiver or deferral of this requirement.
PREA requirements are triggered by the submission of an application or supplement
for a new active ingredient, new indication, new dosage form, new dosing
regimen, or new route of administration.
However, prior to 2020, PREA had little or no effect on
oncology because most applications for adult cancer drugs were exempt,
due either to their orphan drug designation or because the pediatric study
requirement was waived based on the adult cancer indication, which did not occur
in pediatrics. In 2017, the FDA
Reauthorization Act, or FDARA, amended PREA under the RACE for
Children Act to require pediatric investigations of certain targeted
cancer drugs with new active ingredients based on molecular mechanism of
action rather than clinical indication.
Specifically, if the drug is directed at a molecular target FDA determines to
be substantially relevant to the growth or progression of a pediatric
cancer.
More recently, the Mikayla Nilon Give Kids a Chance Act was signed into law in
February 2026 after unanimous passage by the House of
Representatives. This bill modifies the FDARA requirements relating
to molecularly targeted pediatric cancer investigations to require
research on new drugs used in combination with active ingredients that
have already been approved and that, one, have been determined to be part of the
standard of care for treating a pediatric cancer, or, two, have been approved to
treat an adult cancer and are directed at molecular targets for
pediatric cancer. It also renews FDA's authority to
issue priority review vouchers to sponsors of new products to treat rare
pediatric diseases, a substantial incentive, through September
2029.
Finally, our global colleagues are essential to assuring alignment on pediatric
oncology drug development to increase equitable access to new therapies
across international lines. The pediatric cancer community is well accustomed to
working with colleagues from all over the world to reduce duplicative studies in
the face of limited patient resources.
And likewise, the FDA has frequent interactions with the EMA and other
global regulatory agencies, both formally through common commentaries and
Project Orbis, to name two, and informally.
International consortia are critical when discussing early and late-phase trials
for these rare populations.
So the key takeaways for me are that regulatory
evaluations for first-in-child studies consider the age of the patient, the type
of cancer, existing adult and/or pre-clinical data, and the mechanism of
action of the investigational drug.
There are many ways to facilitate early pediatric oncology drug development through
innovative study design and approaches, and we at the FDA really encourage
frequent interaction to discuss these approaches.
There have been some recent legislation that addresses pediatric drug
development through regulatory requirements and financial incentives.
And as I think we all agree, pediatric oncology drug development should always be
thoughtfully designed for children, and we at the FDA consider it
also important to discuss these development programs early with us.
I want to acknowledge the panel, and the entire wonderful team working in
pediatric oncology at the FDA. Thank you.
All right.
Good afternoon, everyone. It is a real pleasure and a
privilege to be here, and I thank AACR and the organizers
for including me in this wonderful session.
And thanks to my panelists for setting the stage.
SoMy title is Planning for Success, and I think all of us
enter into this hoping for success.
And I'm really going to build on the wonderful example
that Dr. McKeon presented of Revumenib and the
challenges, and really focus this on the development of
oral agents. I have no disclosures.
I'll review some key features, and I will present
additional examples of small molecules that actually
have successfully attained approval across the age continuum,
not all of those simultaneously with the initial approval, but--
And this is not exhaustive, these are just examples to highlight key points,
discuss key learnings from these examples, and offer suggestions.
So you saw this from Dr. Erwin, but this is really still
the landscape, is we really are
lagging behind, and in almost every case, the
adult development
precedes the pediatric oncology development.
We also are faced with really low incidence that
require, as Dr. Dresner highlighted,
multi-center, multidisciplinary trials.
We have to
be focused on the goal of improving outcomes,
and we really require the integration of biology, and we
continue to have lags in initiations of trials and really
need trial designs that allow us to accelerate this
pace.
So this is data that has been presented
on the first thousand patients on the NCI Pediatric Match,
emphasizing really the very low rates of
actionable mutations, which you can see here in the upper above this
line. So these are the actionable mutations.
We are actually going to spend a fair bit of time talking about BRAF, which
actually constituted 4% of all the
alterations detected in this patient population.
And duly note that the majority of
alterations are below this line, and the biggest one
being TP53, which we
actually cannot target. So the majority of the
agents that I will be focusing on are in this really small
set of patients with molecular alterations.
So there are strategies to prioritize drugs for pediatric development.
I'm not really going to talk much about biology
or pre-clinical or really clinical data, but really focus
this conversation on drug availability and
formulation that has been highlighted, particularly in the Revumenib
presentation.
So why is it important to think about
studying children across the age continuum?
Children are not just small adults.
They are growing, developing beings, and
they change over time. And so when we think
about the fastest rate of growth, that is in the first 10 years,
and it is exponentially the first 10 years
that there's a tenfold increase in body weight.
This is accompanied by
a proportional change in organ discretory
and particularly renal and hepatic function that really dictate how
drugs are metabolized and utilized in pediatric patients.
And we actually need to consider these aspects
as we think about formulations, not just with the ability to take the drugs, but
with how they actually are utilized by a pediatric patient.
So what is the impact of drug formulation? Dr.
McKeon highlighted this, I think, beautifully.
I say it, IV is easy.
You don't have to do much. It's easy to administer.
It may be a patient burden, but it is, from a drug development point of
view, much easier.
Oral,
we really need to think about basing eligibility on
size, i.e.
body surface area, and not necessarily weight,
as highlighted by the variability in weight across the age,
given that when we are dosing per kilogram, we are
actually underdosing the smallest patients,
which BSA allows us to
mitigate.
As noted, we have to think about available strengths and formulation,
not exclusively on age,
because there are older patients
that may not be able to swallow certain tablets or
capsules, and this is not necessarily exclusively an age limit.
There are many challenges, as Dr. McKeon highlighted, with formulation
development, including solubility, palatability and taste,
and crushability. Most tablets cannot be
split due to variable distribution of the active agent of the
drug within the tablet. So there's a lot of
work that has to go into this, as Dr. McKeon highlighted.
And currently,
as has been highlighted,
companies delay development of pediatric formulations until adult
indication is clear.
And hopefully, as Dr. Dresner indicated, the RACE Act will
mitigate this. So I'm going to highlight
briefly these six examples, and I'm really
going to spend the majority of the time comparing the two
NTRK inhibitors, Larotrectinib and Entrectinib,
that had very different paths to FDA approval,
and then focus on these others very briefly.
So Larotrectinib is a
TRK
inhibitor,
pan-TRK inhibitor, and this was developed by Loxo Oncology.
And they basically set out from the get-go saying, "We
need to be able to dose this in children," and
simultaneously developed a capsule
formulation and a liquid formulation.And what they
also importantly did is they essentially almost
simultaneously launched three separate
trials that included
pediatric patients,
one with adults, and
I'll show you on the timeline, they started with the adults and then rolled this
out. They also importantly, across their three trials,
included the primary endpoints that were consistent across
all these trials, allowing for
similarity of the data across the age continuum.
So this is data from Dr. Leisha's publication
demonstrating if you had an
NTRK abnormality,
you had a tremendous response to this agent.
So when you have such an effect size, you don't need very many
patients to demonstrate a benefit.
So this is the timeline.
So the first patient
was basically treated in 2015.
NAVIGATE was the adult
greater than 18 trial that opened very shortly
after that
in later 2015. The pediatric trial
opened in December of 2015. So there was
very little interval between the pediatric
trial and the adult trial as far as activation.
Very different than the data on the first
slide with the six and a half year emphasis.
So that
data was presented very
early afterwards as abstract form from the adult
study.
And what happened was this very quickly
allowed for the development almost simultaneously
across the age continuum with endpoints that were merged,
ultimately leading to the FDA approval in 2018
across the age continuum in approximately three
years, which is pretty remarkable. I think Dr.
McKeon was five years,
which is also incredibly remarkable.
So let's compare and contrast this to entrectinib, another NTRK
inhibitor, and this was initially approved in
2019 for pediatric patients ages
12 and up with NTRK fusion-positive solid tumors.
The FDA expanded this approval, and I'll show you the timelines
across the age continuum to include greater than one
year. So what did this look like, comparing this to what we saw for
larotrectinib?
Actually, entrectinib was the initial
NTRK inhibitor with the adult Phase 1 study opening in 2012.
And as you saw, larotrectinib, the first patient was dosed in
2015.
The adult trial Phase 1, called STARTRK-1,
opened in 2014.
They completed that study,
generating a recommended Phase 2 dose, a flat dose of 600
milligrams per day, and launched a Phase 2 study
in 2015, so roughly about a year later.
The pediatric
study opened in mid-2016 as a Phase 1/2 study
called STARTRK-NG, which is important and
something we heard about regarding revumenib.
Thinking towards formulation developments for patients who
needed
tube
administration of the drug. So long and short of it,
the initial FDA approval was in 2019,
and that was for patients greater than 12 years of age.
And a second trial was opened,
a Phase 2 trial, on a platform
called TAPESTRY,
where entrectinib was one of the arms on that trial.
And the data from the STARTRK
trial and the arm on TAPESTRY with entrectinib
was pooled to lead to the FDA expanded
approval to less than one year of age.
And the big reason that
there was this significant time delay
was because the drug was
incredibly insoluble and very difficult to formulate,
and it was lipid based. And so there were a lot of challenges in
developing a formulation that actually could decrease
the age down to one.
So let's compare and contrast. So larotrectinib
led to this histology and age agnostic approval
because there was an oral formulation and capsules available and
almost simultaneous studies of pediatric and adults.
Entrectinib, the Phase 1
study
developed a recommended Phase 2 dose of
550 milligrams per meter squared daily,
which was more than the adult recommended Phase 2 dose.
The ultimate expansion, and this led to the approval in
2019 that was BSA based and banded based
on the flat dosing because there was only the 100 and 200 milligram capsules
available.
That was expanded with the ultimate development
after multiple iterations, these mini tablets that
allowed for dosing and into a suspension
that allowed for dosing across the age continuum.
So
let's switch.
So that really shows the importance of thinking ahead of the
development of a friendly formulation and also the challenges as
highlighted by the revumenib story and by the entrectinib
story.Of trying to actually get a formulation that actually is
able to be administered.
An example where this is a combination
approval of two oral agents, a BRAF inhibitor, dabrafenib,
and trametinib, a MEK inhibitor.
This is really focused on BRAF V600E mutation, and as
you saw, that's 4% roughly. And
needs to note, this is focused on the mutation, and
that's going to come important with the next example.
The initial approval
of the combination was made for patients six years and
older.
And this was based on the availability of capsules and tablets
in this age range that could allow for safe dosing
based on a banding of ages six to 17.
As you notice in Dr. Dresner's talk, there are
regulations about the size
that we can include on some of these studies that go down into lower ages.
What was super important about this example is that
there was a phase one dose of dabrafenib
that had been completed, and importantly,
that led to the ability
with two drugs in the same company to actually use
a very smart trial design with four arms, with knowing
the pediatric dose of dabrafenib.
The first monotherapy arm was with trametinib alone,
and then seamlessly into a combination arm, and then
into disease specific cohorts for evaluation of the
combination with titrating for the combination in this
design. So really expedited the development
of the combination by the trial design.
So the combination study, it started in December 2020
and really provided the preliminary single agent data for
trametinib and then the combination so that there could be the
combination comparison. The second phase two
study was really a combination,
was conducted very specifically in low grade and high grade gliomas
because of the enrichment of BRAF V600E
mutations in this patient population.
And so what this led to by this efficient trial
design in March of 2023 was approval
for the combination of patients one year and older with low
grade gliomas and BRAF V600E mutations.
And this was the first approval for frontline therapy
for this patient population. What were the big
advantages of enhancing this combination strategy?
Both agents in the same company, formulations available for both that allowed
rapid translation into the lower
age group, and the trial design.
So
also targeting
BRAF is a second agent,
toverafenib. And so the biology here is really
important because trametinib and
dabrafenib were approved for BRAF V600E
mutations. This
here, I'm bringing back, says that half of these are
mutations, the other half are fusions.
And BRAF and fusions, trametinib and
dabrafenib do not affect the fusions.
So this was very much based on a different biology.
And because there was formulation
considerations simultaneously with the development
of this drug,
they
were able to actually very rapidly go
to FDA approval for patients six months and older for
relapsed refractory low grade
gliomas, including BRAF fusions.
So very importantly based on the biology, but also the recognition that
concurrently the formulation was developed.
Dordabifene is also an
example of having the formulation simultaneously.
And so this led to the approval based on 50
patients across a combined aggregate data set
of five studies allowing
for FDA approval in August of 2025
for patients one year and older.
And again, an example of having the formulation
available to lead to the approval of this inhibitor.
And the last example is selumetinib.
Again, this is an important approval.
FDA approved for patients
with NF1 based inoperable plexiform
neurofibromas in 2020, ages two years and up.
But this was based on capsule strength formulations,
and subsequent to that approval,
AstraZeneca launched a trial called SPRINKLE, which
importantly was a granular formulation that allowed for expansion
of this approval in 2025 for patients
one year and older.
So key considerations for pediatric early phase trials.
We need adequate safety and dosing data in children.
Formulation is key, and it's critical to
the issues surrounding dosing and accuracy of dosing.
We have to have detailed PK
across this and limit dose exploration to be able to have the
most appropriate formulations in children.
And we need to really
think about PK and age associated toxicity as well.
Impact of trial design. We need efficient design.
So really super efficient
is it can be
Seamless designs, as was in the trametinib dabrafenib
example, that allow for adequate toxicity PK
data and comparisons for efficacy.
Starting at the recommended phase two dose based on adults
is considered something that can speed things up.
Combination strategies
really should be thought about very efficiently and effectively.
Utilizing basket and umbrella trials or platform designs can also
efficiently add data to the approvals
and, as Dr. Dresner discussed, adolescent cohorts.
So
we have a rare target population, and it's getting
smaller and smaller
. This does require collaboration
with federal agencies, academia, and industry.
All of the trials I presented to you were international trials.
We need international collaborations to make this
happen. And as we have heard
through
all three presentations, we need regulatory
requirement coordination and
basing everything on biology.
So this is from Dr. Steve Dubois, but I think it's still a very
important
visual.
This is historically where we are.
I think the vast majority of us still feel we are still following the adult
development, and we need to get to this point where we're actually
having much more simultaneous and
seamless development across the age continuum.
So thank you, and
I appreciate it.
So I want to thank all the speakers.
I wonder if anybody has a question before we maybe start a discussion.
Are there any questions from the audience?
Great.
Hi, thank you so much for sharing the great stories. I'm Yuta Sano from Genentech.
So there have been a lot of detailed discussions about drug
formulation, but could you also share unique
challenges or considerations you had to make in terms of clinical
biomarker strategies for patients, those pediatric patients, if any?
Jerry, do you want to maybe start-- Are you--
A biomarker?
Yeah, or
you had worked a lot, I know, with translational researchers all along the way, and
I wonder if...
Well,
I have to say MENET actually, the target is unique.
We didn't ever develop a biomarker for it.
So it was really just a reduction in the blast count was a true
indicator of the on-target activity.
And
we did end up doing some
pools from patients after short treatments, and basically doing sequencing on
some of the blasts and showing that we did kick the
transcriptional program in the direction that we wanted.
But essentially, blast counts were being monitored weekly, and they were coming
down, so that was our real titration, is looking at where we were on
those response.
Yeah, I was guessing you cannot draw the same amount of blood
from patients or that you need to restrict what you can
test or that kind of thing. So yeah.
Thank you.
Hi, everyone. Nice session. Sorry I missed the beginning of it, but
hopefully you didn't talk about this. So this is actually a question for Dr.
Dresner from the FDA.
One topic that's been coming up recently in my conversations with potential
industry partners for trials, mostly in adolescent patients, because that's what
I do, is this question of, if we were going for approval in
that particular indication and we were looking at combination therapy, this
question about the new guidance about principal components.
Do you think about principal components differently?
Like that thing where you have to show that each one of the drugs in a combination
therapy is contributing to the effect of a combination
regimen. I think that's what it is.
Do you think about it differently in younger patients, rare
tumors, or that's like a one size fits all
guidance?
Thanks for the question. No, it's definitely not one size fits all.
And I think we are generally, for rare diseases,
pretty
creative and flexible in the way that we think about how the contribution of
components can be
described for each agent.
And sometimes it really only takes just a little bit of data.
Dr. Weigel, you mentioned the dabrafenib trametinib example, which is a great
example
of a study where they had a small cohort of patients who
received each agent as a single agent,
but really not very many patients.
And so we
based our rationale for the need for the combination
based on that, and also the experience using that same combination
and other
similar drugs in combination in other cancers.
So I think we're very willing to apply a reasonable
approach, and do not expect
large single-arm cohorts of
each agent in the combination,
particularly if it's a combination that's been used as part
of standard of care, and if there's also some pre-clinical data
demonstrating that that single agent really wouldn't be effective.
Thanks. Dr. Donahue?
Hi, this is Martha Donahue, FDA. And this question's for Dr. McGeehan.
Thank you so much for providing your insights on the whole
development program for revimenib, and I was thinking about your story or
revimenib's story, coupled along with the
contrast that Dr. Weigel presented in terms of the time it takes to
approve pediatric indications for
drugs that really have clear applicability to pediatric patients,
but for which sometimes there can be a long lag with your product
and larotrectinib and tovorafenib being on one side of the spectrum
And I'd say debrafenib and trametinib and others, taking longer.
And one thing that we've heard, and I think this kind of was discussed a
little bit in the previous session that Sam Blackman and Ted Laish
and Beth Fox were just in, talking about the economics of developing products
for pediatrics is the financial considerations and
when is the... So what I'm thinking about and wanted to ask you is your insights
regarding
from that perspective, when is the right time to start developing a pediatric
formulation in earnest? What prompted you to your company
to consider this early? And obviously, that created success, but there
can also be a lot of financial outlay and risk that you're taking on early in
development when you decide to go that route.
So if you could just provide a little bit of that thought process, that'd be great.
I think this was a unique one since it was unusually tied to
infants and peds from its inception.
So, and it was always our commitment to basically
try to get to that population as quickly as possible.
I can imagine in another indication, I think people, once they had
compelling POC in the adult population, I
think that's probably about the right time to start thinking about how to move it
into pediatrics as quickly as possible.
And
there is a cost associated with that, and so there's always a moment of inertia,
and
it depends on the people inside, actually, if they're committed to it.
And I think if there's an economic case-- not just an
economic case, but an ethical case be made for it,
people would probably go for it. So...
And then thank you. And in terms of any of the regulatory financial
incentives for developing pediatrics, did those come into play for you at all?
No. No. We actually didn't consider those at all when the...
We probably should've been more versed in them, but we...
No, it really was,
once we knew we had a soluble compound before we even went to the clinic, we
thought, "Okay, this is not going to be very hard.
It's going to take a little," but
the actual oral formulation took years to mask the taste and get a stable
form. It was
quite a haul, and some investment as well, but I think the
company had a commitment to make sure it was available to everybody across all age
groups. And I think it's really a company commitment at the end of the day.
It's probably not just based purely on the economics. It's about the patient need.
So...
Thank you.
That's really nice to hear.
At least our company.
At least.
Question for the whole panel. My name's Ken Alexander.
I think I'm the token infectious disease person here.
I've spent my career watching antiretrovirals become
available for small children.
Was there anything to be gained in our experiences there,
making drugs available to children very quickly, that can be
transferred to the oncology world?
I guess I also wondered if you thought there were some things from your experience
that-
Whichever.
We sure tried.
Okay.
Yeah.
No.
Well, I will say that the sort of the antiretroviral world really
launched the accelerated approval process,
which has certainly been largely used these days through
oncology, and I think that that can be
leveraged by pediatric cancer development programs.
I don't know the specifics of pediatric antiretroviral
development, but if there are creative ways that you've developed to get those
drugs
across regulatory approval faster, that would be a fascinating
discussion to have. We'd be open to hearing.
Sure.
Yeah. And I think one of the things, and I think it
has helped in the pediatric oncology world, in
retroviral therapies, and it's akin
to Dr. McKeon, infants have been very
much targeted across
the age continuum. So those considerations and
those approval processes do help in informing
how certain companies think about getting into the
formulation needs of especially the smallest children.
And the dosing, I think it's also we learn as well
through those examples for sure.
And just to add, about the accelerated approval process, and I think the
antiretroviral story sort of
developed that pathway through the use of surrogate or intermediate endpoints
using viral loads. And I think that that is certainly
applicable
in many cases in pediatric development where we
are thinking about endpoints that maybe aren't the standard
resist assessed response criteria and which endpoints can support
the different approval pathways.
I actually had a question,
maybe for everyone, but especially Dr. Dresner and Weigel.
The single patient protocol mechanism that was
outlined for REV. I like calling it REV, it's much more easier.
It's easier, yeah.
Yeah. It really struck me as something we
maybe don't tap into enough, and I was thinking a little bit from the
FDA's perspective about that. I can say, being from Canada, it's
actually one of the mechanisms we use with Health Canada to
evaluate drugs in our patients that aren't approved, and we don't have a mechanism
otherwise to get those medications.
So I wondered if you could speak to that, and then maybe, Dr.
Weigel, how should we think about that in our consortiums and our groups, thinking
creatively. I think you and others talked about out of the box.
How should we put this into our list of approaches?
Yes.
So I think that
although our preference is not for development programs to be conducted under a
series of single patient INDs, we
have certainly utilized data in rare
populations that we can
collect from single patient INDs to
provide supportive evidence, especially in
very rare populations when we're doing an approval based
on 30 or 40 patients. The single patient IND and
expanded access experience can give us
a lot of good supportive data that we
use in different approvals.
It obviously depends on how well that's collected, and if we see
a number of single patient INDs coming in, we usually ask that those
be shunted either into ideally a full research
protocol, but if not that, then an expanded access protocol where there's at
least
time points that are systematically created for response assessment so that we
can
make the best
use of that data as possible. But there are examples, and we'll
talk about a few actually in the next section on extrapolation, but
specifically vorasidenib for IDH mutant low grade glioma,
which was an adult randomized trial that was open to adolescents but
didn't enroll any. We asked the company to search
through their single patient IND and expanded access database to provide us
any safety or also efficacy data on
adolescent patients that have received that as part of a single patient IND
process, and we used it in our approval decision.
That's great, because when I think of the landscape analysis for match that
was shown in the third talk, there are going to be some
of these alterations that we see in one or two children that maybe are only
seen in adults or when we have the rare colorectal or some other
malignancy that's really an adult malignancy. It would be great to have that.
Did you have a word to add, Brenda?
I'll
draw a slight distinction and Dr. Dresner can jump in,
but I think
what Dr. McKeon presented was a single patient protocol that
was initiated at the company.
Yeah.
And so that's data that
is different than when an investigator
approaches the regulators to initiate
a single patient IND, if you will, for a
patient they have. So from my perspective,
one of the challenges
with single patient INDs,
I think as Dr. Dresner was saying, is there's a lot
of variability in what's collected, what
the standards are, what the observations.
A single patient protocol, which I think the FDA now
has more
guidances around these single patient
trials, if you will. There's more
rigor with regards to the data that's collected, which I think is really
important if we're thinking about future access for pediatrics,
and especially if it's an ultra
rare circumstance, because I think there is
merit in providing access to a very targeted agent in
an ultra rare patient population.
And I'm looking at Dr. Donahue because I know there's huge
efforts
ongoing in this ultra rare situation,
which I think is more akin to what Dr.
McKeon was describing, rather than a one-off
patient.
Yeah. We used a single patient protocol almost out of need.
Yes.
Because we needed to get those data to satisfy the criteria for
opening the enrollment to the piece.
And then we had a lot of requests, expanded access-
Yes
... compassionate use, and we ground around for a while, saying that,
"We need to get the data."
Right.
It has to be something that's, as you said, rigorous.
Set timelines for PK, everything like that, the same measures across them all.
And that's when we ended up using the SPPs, and it really was
to our advantage because our real target was to get enrollment of the
pediatrics as quickly as possible.
So it was almost out of
complete necessity that we went there.
Yeah, there-
As I said, it ended up being a lift. We actually literally had to hire
another person because we were getting these things pouring over the transom, so it
was a lot.
Yeah, when we start hearing from Project Facilitate, which manages our single
patient IND submissions, that there are a lot coming in, we will generally reach
out to companies and ask for a protocol
to be developed so that we can capture that type
of information in a more systematic way.
And there are some ultra-rare diseases
or drug approvals, like I'm thinking about valpelizib for PROS, in which the
expanded access experience was included within the
drug label itself.
That's great.
I guess the last thing I was just going to ask before we close is, we talked a lot
about molecularly targeted drugs.
Are there any other things we should think about with all the immunotherapies,
or is it really following similar sorts of paradigms?
Anything from you, anybody on the
panel, short or not?
Basically, any ideas about this, or is it all the same lessons?
It's really just whether there's any difference.
No, I think there are some key differences.
I think
formulation is not so much an issue.
It becomes more dosing and exposure, and ensuring that,
and especially with things like antibodies,
it does make a difference. And then we have multiple examples where dosing
per kilo actually underdosed the youngest patients because of higher
clearance in the younger patients.
And so there are really key
things to really think about, and that's whereIt really
becomes you want equivalent exposures, and the
PK and the ability to dose and how you
dose in using a lot of the immunotherapies,
protein-based
drugs
is
really critical to consider. So it's not so much a formulation, but
it still speaks to the critical need for thinking about how to
actually dose the smallest children.
And these are biologics for the most part, right?
Most of these are biologics, so they are sort of handled
differently metabolically by
children, and very much for a lot of them affected by
renal and hepatic function.
Do you have the ability to step up the dose?
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
All right.
And I think one of the things that is the same between those two classes is
the importance of when we receive proposals or
pre-IND proposals for new clinical trial in pediatric
patients, I really can't speak enough about the importance of having
proof of concept or pre-clinical information in that
package to support that. Because I think you will find that
we
will be flexible and creative when there is a strong
rationale, where the proposal is not something like, "Well, this drug is
being used in adult glioblastoma, so it must be also applicable
to children." We like the pediatric specific
rationale to be included and the work to be done when possible, when the models
exist.
And so the PPTC has been renamed, right?
Yeah.
It's P-- So,
okay. But I will tell you, for us, that was a phenomenal resource.
Yeah.
And I was introduced to Malcolm Smith probably 2015,
2016. And Richard Lock's lab did a phenomenal job
in Children's at Sydney. Yeah, and I know there are, I think,
seven of those in the consortium, basically for
targeting rare cancers.
Yeah.
So.
But I would advise anybody to take a look at it and what's in that
consortium, because it is a phenomenal resource.
Great. Well, I want to thank all
three speakers and all of you for the great discussion.
And I hope you have a great rest of the meeting.
Thank you so much, all three, for this great discussion.
That was great.